Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode 4, Part Two.
Now the world changes.
After the Second World War, Denmark changed a lot.
Denmark gave up its traditional policy of neutrality and became a member of NATO in 1949.
Domestically too, the post-war period brought great changes, not least because of the rapidly growing economic prosperity.
Danes got more money in their hands than ever before.
Towards the end of the 1960s, disagreements between younger and older generations grew, because more young people questioned many of society's traditional norms.
The world had become a different place after the Second World War.
Millions of people had been killed during the war, and many cities in Europe lay in ruins.
The war had created a strong wish to secure international peace and security.
In 1945, a number of countries therefore founded the United Nations, the UN.
Denmark was a member of the UN from the start, which was meant, among other things, to help prevent a new world war.
After the Second World War, the Cold War arose between the two new superpowers, the USA and the Soviet Union.
It was an ideological struggle and an arms race over, among other things, nuclear weapons, between the Western democracies based on liberal market economy on one side, and the communist countries based on planned economy on the other.
Europe was divided into a west and an east along a line that especially reflected which areas had been liberated from Nazi Germany in the Second World War, by the USA and Great Britain in the west, and by the Soviet Union in the east.
The division between east and west became known as the Iron Curtain.
The Cold War came to shape the world until the communist dictatorships in Eastern Europe fell around 1990.
Denmark had tried to remain neutral in international conflicts since the England Wars at the beginning of the 1800s.
But since the policy of neutrality could not prevent the German occupation in the Second World War, Denmark chose a side in the Cold War.
It felt better protected as a member of the defence alliance NATO, the North Atlantic Treaty Organisation.
In 1949 Denmark therefore became a member of NATO.
The alliance consisted of the USA, Canada, Turkey, and a number of Western European countries.
Central in the NATO treaty is Article 5, the so-called "musketeer oath".
It says that an armed attack on one member country shall be regarded as an attack on all the member countries.
This obliges the other NATO countries, if necessary also with military force, to help the country that has been attacked.
Remember it: Article 5, the musketeer oath.
Opposite NATO stood the Warsaw Pact, which was founded in 1955.
This defence alliance was led by the communist Soviet Union, which got great influence over the countries of Eastern Europe after the Second World War.
After almost one hundred years under Germany's influence, Denmark's foreign and security policy after the Second World War was oriented especially towards the USA.
The USA played an important role in the rebuilding of Western Europe after the Second World War.
In the years 1948 to 51, the USA gave very large sums of money to several Western European countries, among others Denmark.
The money was given as part of the Marshall Plan, named after the American foreign minister George Marshall.
The purpose of the Marshall Aid was to get international trade, which had come to a halt during the Second World War, going again.
In that way, they also hoped to prevent communism from spreading further in Western Europe.
The economic help from the USA contributed to modernising Danish agriculture in the first decades after the Second World War.
Hundreds of thousands of horses were replaced by tractors, combine harvesters and other machines.
A large part of the workforce in the countryside therefore became superfluous, and many people moved from the rural areas into the towns in the 1950s.
The first election after the war, in 1945, resulted in a centre-right government under Venstre's leadership, but in 1947 the Social Democrats regained government power.
The Communist Party of Denmark, DKP, got relatively large support with twelve and a half percent of the votes at the election in 1945, because large parts of the population sympathised with the fact that many Danish communists had taken part in the resistance struggle during the occupation, and with the Soviet Union's considerable effort in defeating Nazi Germany.
Most of the party's new voters, however, quickly left it again.
The vast majority of voters continued to vote for the four old parties: the Social Democrats, the Social Liberal Party, the Conservative People's Party and Venstre.
The Danish tradition of political stability and agreement on the basic democratic rules of the game continued during the Cold War.
The Soviet-supported communists never gained a share of government power in Denmark.
In the post-war period, people began again to discuss whether there was a need to change the constitution.
In a referendum in 1953, a majority voted to change the constitution.
The change meant, among other things, that the Landsting was abolished.
Instead, a so-called one-chamber system was introduced, with the Folketing as the only legislative assembly.
In addition, the constitution now also applied to Greenland, and not only to Denmark and the Faroe Islands.
The succession to the throne was also changed, so that the Danish throne could pass to a woman.
However, sons still came before daughters, which means a younger son would still inherit the throne if he had an older sister.
The question of a female succession was particularly pressing because the then king, Frederik the Ninth, who reigned from nineteen forty-seven to seventy-two, had three daughters and no sons.
The constitutional change in 1953 thereby made it possible for his eldest daughter, the later Queen Margrethe the Second, who reigned from nineteen seventy-two to twenty twenty-four, to inherit the throne.
With a change to the Act of Succession in 2009, men and women got completely equal right of inheritance to the throne, so that it is always the eldest, son or daughter, who inherits the throne.
It was the Social Democrats who had the greatest political influence in the first decades after the Second World War.
From 1953 to 1968, all governments in Denmark were led by the Social Democrats.
The only party that emerged in this period, and which is still in the Folketing, is SF, the Socialist People's Party.
SF was formed in 1959 by a group of people who left DKP in protest against the communist countries' oppression of their populations, which the breakaways did not think DKP distanced itself enough from.
The crushing of the popular uprising against communist rule in Hungary in 1956 was decisive for the split of DKP.
Now, the good times.
From the end of the 1950s there was high economic growth in Europe, including in Denmark, which in the period 1957 to 73 had an economic boom almost without parallel in the country's history.
There was full employment and a big increase in production, just as most incomes grew steadily in this period.
The period has therefore often been called "the happy sixties", De glade 60'ere.
From the beginning of the 1960s, Denmark exported more industrial goods than agricultural goods.
It was also in this period that the building of the Danish welfare society really began, and an ever larger social safety net was spread under the population.
Several of the schemes that underlie today's Danish welfare society were established in those years, just as many of the existing schemes were considerably expanded.
The old-age pension, folkepensionen, which gives every citizen the right to a pension regardless of income, was for example introduced in 1956.
And in 1964, the Folketing decided that the municipalities must create the necessary number of day-care places, so that all families could have the opportunity to get their children into nursery and kindergarten.
The expansion of the welfare state also meant that taxes and duties rose a lot in this period.
The growth also meant that more labour was needed.
Many Danish women came out onto the labour market.
In the middle of the 1900s, the vast majority of married women had looked after house and children, while men went to work outside the home.
From the 1960s, women increasingly got education and work.
And many more children spent part of the day in one of the many new nurseries, kindergartens and after-school clubs that were set up.
Women, however, often got lower pay than men for the same work, and the fight to secure equality between men and women became stronger.
The economic growth meant that many more people suddenly got access to consumer goods beyond the most basic necessities such as food, clothes and housing.
TV sets, record players, fridges, freezers, washing machines, detached houses, cars and more had until then been regarded as luxury goods that only the richest could afford.
Now they became to a far greater extent part of most people's lives.
On top of the increased prosperity, the working week was continuously shortened, from forty-eight to forty hours between 1958 and 1974, and people got more holiday, from two to four weeks between 1953 and 1972.
So there were now far more people who had time and money to travel abroad on holiday or to buy a summer house.
And then the young people stood up.
At the end of the 1960s, in Denmark as in many other Western countries, there were clear tensions between the generations.
Young people's resistance to society's norms and authorities grew, and they therefore rebelled.
Many young people, especially in the bigger towns, broke with society's traditional norms and values.
Among other things, they questioned the USA's participation in the war in Vietnam, and the "nuclear family" with father, mother and children as society's supporting unit.
Instead came a freer attitude to sexual relations, also before marriage.
From 1966, the contraceptive pill could be sold legally in Denmark.
Women thereby gained access to an easy contraceptive, so that they themselves could control whether they wanted to become pregnant and have children.
The pill therefore became of decisive importance for women's sexual liberation.
New ways of living together also became more accepted.
For example, a couple could live together and have children without being married.
Some young people sought new ways of living together, among other things in communes.
Others experimented with narcotic drugs.
The free town of Christiania in Copenhagen was established in 1971, when young people occupied an abandoned military barracks, Bådsmandsstræde Barracks.
After that, up to one thousand people settled in Christiania and tried to live out many of the new ideas of the time.
The free town of Christiania still exists.
The youth revolt also led to a student revolt.
In 1968 and the years after, many students and younger teachers rebelled against the so-called professor rule at the universities.
They demanded more influence, new forms of management and teaching, and a different content of the studies, and they succeeded in getting many of their demands through.
The stricter and more authoritarian upbringing of children in families and schools was also replaced by an education based on increased dialogue and cooperation between children and adults.
Among other things, it became completely forbidden in 1967 for teachers to hit pupils in the Danish folkeskole.
It was, however, thirty years later, in 1997, that it also became completely forbidden for parents to hit their own children.
Here's your recap for Episode Four.
The Danish military resistance on the ninth of April lasted only a few hours.
The cooperation policy ran from 1940 to 1943.
The boom of 1957 to 73 was called the happy sixties.
The youth revolt questioned the nuclear family, and made it accepted to have children without being married.
Margrethe the Second became queen in 1972.
The Soviet forces left Bornholm in the spring of 1946.
Since 1953 the constitution applies in Greenland and the Faroe Islands.
Frederik the Ninth's three daughters were Margrethe, born 1940, Benedikte, born 1944, and Anne-Marie, born 1946.
The occupation began on the ninth of April, 1940.
The government's cooperation policy ended on the twenty-ninth of August, 1943.
The Freedom Council was founded in September 1943.
More than seven thousand of about eight thousand Danish Jews escaped.
Iceland declared its republic on the seventeenth of June, 1944.
Denmark was liberated on the fifth of May, 1945, and about seven thousand Danes were killed.
Denmark joined the UN in 1945 and NATO in 1949, with Article 5 as the musketeer oath.
The Marshall Plan ran from 1948 to 51.
The constitution changed in 1953, with one chamber and a female succession.
The old-age pension came in 1956, and SF was formed in 1959.
The pill arrived in 1966, hitting by teachers was banned in 1967, Christiania began in 1971, and hitting by parents was banned in 1997.
In Episode Five, Denmark joins Europe, and the oil runs short.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which international organisation did Denmark become a member of in 1945?
Option A: The UN.
Option B: The EC.
Option C: The WTO.
[DA] Hvilken international organisation blev Danmark medlem af i 1945?  A: FN  |  B: EF  |  C: WTO
The answer is A: The UN.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in November 2024.
[DA] ✔ A: FN
Question 2.
When did Denmark become a member of NATO?
Option A: 1949.
Option B: 1957.
Option C: 1973.
[DA] Hvornår blev Danmark medlem af NATO?  A: 1949  |  B: 1957  |  C: 1973
The answer is A: 1949.
It appeared in the May 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1949
Question 3.
What is NATO?
Option A: An international free trade area.
Option B: An international defence alliance.
Option C: An international refugee cooperation.
[DA] Hvad er NATO?  A: Et internationalt frihandelsområde  |  B: En international forsvarsalliance  |  C: Et internationalt flygtningesamarbejde
The answer is B: An international defence alliance.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: En international forsvarsalliance
Question 4.
What characterised Denmark's defence policy through most of the Cold War?
Option A: Denmark was allied with the Soviet Union through the Warsaw Pact.
Option B: Denmark was neutral.
Option C: Denmark was allied with the USA through NATO.
[DA] Hvad kendetegnede Danmarks forsvarspolitik gennem det meste af Den Kolde Krig?  A: Danmark var allieret med Sovjetunionen gennem Warszawa-pagten  |  B: Danmark var neutralt  |  C: Danmark var allieret med USA gennem NATO
The answer is C: Denmark was allied with the USA through NATO.
It appeared in the November 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danmark var allieret med USA gennem NATO
Question 5.
When did Denmark receive economic help from the USA under the Marshall Plan?
Option A: Around 1920.
Option B: Around 1950.
Option C: Around 1980.
[DA] Hvornår fik Danmark økonomisk hjælp fra USA i forbindelse med Marshall-planen?  A: Omkring 1920  |  B: Omkring 1950  |  C: Omkring 1980
The answer is B: Around 1950.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Omkring 1950
Question 6.
Which political party was formed in the late 1950s as a breakaway from the Communist Party of Denmark, DKP?
Option A: The Red-Green Alliance.
Option B: The Social Liberal Party.
Option C: The Socialist People's Party, SF.
[DA] Hvilket politisk parti blev dannet i slutningen af 1950’erne som udbryder af Danmarks Kommunistiske Parti (DKP)?  A: Enhedslisten  |  B: Det Radikale Venstre  |  C: Socialistisk Folkeparti
The answer is C: The Socialist People's Party, SF.
It appeared in the November 2021, November 2023 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Socialistisk Folkeparti
Question 7.
What did the latest amendment of the constitution, in 1953, involve, among other things?
Option A: That the voting age was lowered to eighteen.
Option B: That women could inherit the throne.
Option C: That Denmark became a member of the UN.
[DA] Hvad indebar den seneste ændring af grundloven i 1953 blandt andet?  A: At valgretsalderen blev sænket til 18 år  |  B: At kvinder fik mulighed for at arve tronen  |  C: At Danmark blev medlem af FN
The answer is B: That women could inherit the throne.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: At kvinder fik mulighed for at arve tronen
Question 8.
Does the constitution apply in the Faroe Islands and Greenland?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Gælder grundloven på Færøerne og i Grønland?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the May 2024 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 9.
When was the first law on the old-age pension adopted?
Option A: 1933.
Option B: 1956.
Option C: 1982.
[DA] Hvornår blev den første lov om folkepension vedtaget?  A: 1933  |  B: 1956  |  C: 1982
The answer is B: 1956.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1956
Question 10.
Which decade was especially characterised by high growth, full employment and a big increase in production?
Option A: The 1960s.
Option B: The 1970s.
Option C: The 1980s.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende årtier var især kendetegnet ved høj vækst, fuld beskæftigelse og stor stigning i produktionen?  A: 1960’erne  |  B: 1970’erne  |  C: 1980’erne
The answer is A: The 1960s.
It appeared in the November 2021, November 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1960’erne
Question 11.
Which of the following did some young people become critical of in the 1960s?
Option A: The nuclear family.
Option B: Early retirement pay.
Option C: Social media.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende områder stillede en del unge sig kritisk over for i 1960’erne?  A: Kernefamilien  |  B: Efterlønnen  |  C: De sociale medier
The answer is A: The nuclear family.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Kernefamilien
Question 12.
When did a larger group of young people rebel against society's traditional norms, so that, for example, it became more accepted to have children without being married?
Option A: At the end of the 1920s.
Option B: At the end of the 1940s.
Option C: At the end of the 1960s.
[DA] Hvornår gjorde en større gruppe af unge oprør mod samfundets traditionelle normer, så det fx blev mere accepteret at få børn uden at være gift?  A: I slutningen af 1920’erne  |  B: I slutningen af 1940’erne  |  C: I slutningen af 1960’erne
The answer is C: At the end of the 1960s.
It appeared in the June 2021, November 2022 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: I slutningen af 1960’erne
Question 13.
When did it become forbidden for teachers to hit pupils in the folkeskole?
Option A: 1967.
Option B: 1987.
Option C: 2007.
[DA] Hvornår blev det forbudt for lærerne at slå eleverne i folkeskolen?  A: 1967  |  B: 1987  |  C: 2007
The answer is A: 1967.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: 1967
Question 14.
In which year did Margrethe the Second become queen of Denmark?
Option A: 1972.
Option B: 1982.
Option C: 1992.
[DA] Hvilket år blev Margrethe d. 2. dronning af Danmark?  A: 1972  |  B: 1982  |  C: 1992
The answer is A: 1972.
It appeared in the June 2022 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1972
That's the end of this part.
Well done.